Disney is one of the largest
entertainment companies in the world
right now they have their hands full
between Marvel Star Wars Pixar and their
own classic properties Disney will be
dominating a theater near you for the
foreseeable future here are some of the
biggest movies to expect down the road
Showtime a hold their first major
release is guardians of the galaxy -
first guardians proved that superhero
movies can be fun mostly we're looking
forward to another awesome soundtrack
sequel to the 2014 sleeper hit comes out
on may 5th 2017 thor ragnarok is the
third movie about the Norse god to prove
that Marvel wants to steer their movies
in a more fun direction they took a
chance by hiring comedy director Te
Kuiti idiots theatres on November 3rd
2017 Marvel fans might be most excited
about the upcoming Black Panther the
character stole the show in Captain
America Civil War the movie starring
chadwick boseman and directed by
accomplished Creed director Ryan Coogler
has a lot of potential you can see
whether or not it lives up to it On
February 16th 2018 in fact 2018 is a big
year for Marvel the next Avengers movie
will be out on May 4th and ant-man in
the loss will be out on July 6 the last
Avengers has been split in two
the final chapter will be shown to the
world on May 3rd 2019 that same year
we're also getting Captain Marvel
starring brie Larson it will be Marvel's
first female lead superhero movie it
comes out on March 8th 2019
in 2012 Disney purchased Lucasfilm for
four billion dollars the company then
made the wise choice of rebooting Star
Wars both for new trilogy and three
separate spin-offs strong Wars Episode
eight the last Jedi will give us even
more time with Luke Skywalker it comes
out on December 15 2017 Episode nine in
which the director wants to actually
shoot parts of the movie in space comes
out May 23rd 2019 I love you
in between there will be a han Solo
centric spinoff set for release on May
25th 2018 one final spin-off looms down
the road nobody knows what it's about
just yet Hakuna Matata ain't no passing
craze installs is the most lucrative
currency at Disney and they're running
on it right now a live-action version of
The Lion King sounds like one of their
more interesting projects it's directed
by Jungle Book and Iron Man helmet Jon
Favreau and so far the cast includes dog
lover Seth Rogen and Billy Eichner it
comes out on July 19th 2019 in late 2018
we'll be getting a live-action Mulan
directed by Nikki Caro and a sequel to
Mary Poppins starring Emily Blunt Meryl
Streep and lin-manuel Miranda Disney
isn't done with the Pirates of the
Caribbean movies just yet the franchise
is a monster hit around the world and
now they'll be treating us two dead men
tell no tales it will likely be one of
the biggest hits of the summer when it
comes out on May 26 2017 Pixar is as
productive as ever
a third Cars movie comes out in June
2017 along the waited sequel to The
Incredibles comes out in June 2018 that
means it's only 14 years late there will
be a fourth that's right fourth Toy
Story movie expected to be a love story
between woody and Bo Peep it comes out
on June 21st 2019 finally Disney's own
animation studio is busy as well they
had a huge Oscar winning 2016 with
Zootopia and Moana
bracket Ralph - which takes its classic
arcade character into the Internet era
comes out on March 9 2018 frozen the
highest-grossing animated movie of all
time is getting the sequel treatment we
won't be shocked if it leads to another
endless stream of merchandise ice shows
and Broadway musicals it comes out on
November 27th 2019 but don't worry
not all sequels Cocco an animated film
centered around the Mexican holiday Dia
de los Muertos will be out on November
22nd 2017
they also have a slew of untitled
releases the last one coming out in 2021
so there you have it this is how Disney
will be keeping you entertained for the
next few years and to infinity and
beyond
[Music]